what are you actively doing what are you
actively doing as an Arab yourself for
the black Africans that Arab are
keeping even
today video ask question
asking to answer he want to hear even
hear answer clearly I made a video if
you watch few times I spoke for example
lib in Libya because theil War
I made a video many times speaking about
this issue which is go and get teacher
Muhammad clearly said whoever goes
around and enslave three people his
prayer will not be accepted right but
like would you wouldn't you agree that
you Muhammad actually kept S
no no no he did but what is
he or no have finish here black people
in
I don't want I
just
okay slave servant what
servant servant not slave no you know
why I tell you why okay clearly that you
standing with a terrorists so you you
know he wants to talk about slavery and
all of that when he has a flag of the
Zionist who are killing children women
in Gaza and you want Muhammad what's
what's ironic
ironic so therefore no no wait wait wait
no no no no no wait if the H if the ham
according to you behave like animals so
therefore it's okay to kill children wom
he defend are you still defend are you
saying it's okay to K children woman are
you about the bab you babies or not he
doesn't care about babies he talk about
slavy but he supporting of the children
wom please can someone out there
rationalize this for me he wasy when
suppor of children womab combat are
brainwashed you are a terrorist
supporter
speak supporter the enemy of my eny is
my friend enemy of my en is my friend 1
years of
enies that what do you for 1,000 years
justifying kill of children justif the K
of a bab for of course you don't want to
do that you a coward coward support
terrorist coward you're coward in prain
you're a country is slave you're talking
about
slavery you're a slave of the zist he's
a slave of the
Zionist us abuse him he's having Iden
slave of the zist and about slavery
Islam look look what's ironic he's a
slave to the Zionist and he want slav in
Islam Subhan Allah I just to clarify
this pointet and use the word servitude
because Islam never came with enslaving
three people the only time when Allah
would to have a servant in a time of War
because as the mentioned Allah create
Adam as a free man this man standing for
a country who are by the way is known
that Israel have poisoned the black
Ethiopians Jewish Jewish black
Ethiopians is known for it they want to
poison them because they have no they
having many children so instead of
Defending CU he seems like he cares
about black people instead of defending
the black Africans in Israel for being
oppressed by the Zionist he tried to
speak about the prophet Muhammad but you
know what
Allah as said anyone that try to wage a
war and
getl except Allah will humiliate him
this person the best example trying to
speak and Prophet
Muhammad me he tried to speak andess
Prophet Muhammad about slavery and
servitude while supporting a Zionist
killers and murderers and those who are
enslaving black people in Israel he
should be on charges he this this guy
should be in a watch list for trying to
justify the murderers and the terror
the Zionist alhamdulillah take brother
we don't speak to terrorist supporters
take we don't
support tell us about the Arab Islam on
today no tell us about that tell us
about the
[Music]
Arab I'm off you know that's how you
doal
with ignore
him f